error mitigation and we're going to go over three of them in more detail be aware however that this is an area of
active research so new techniques will likely be invented and older ones will continue to be improved upon the
resilience level increases the cost or in other words the time it takes to run your job we already said that at
resilience level zero the transpiler doesn't really do anything to your circuit but starting at resilience level one it introduces a method called twirled
readout error Extinction or we call it T-Rex for short twirled readout error Extinction uses poly twirling to
mitigate noise which is something that we've already touched upon it's a very general and effective technique that
intuitively speaking makes the noise less irregular and easier to deal with starting at resilience level two we
introduce zero noise extrapolation or zne for short this is a popular technique that we've recently had a lot
of success with the idea behind Zen might be a bit surprising we actually add additional
noise on top of what's already there but what this does is it allows us to extrapolate in the reverse direction to
predict what the results would look like if there was less noise this can be done in several specific ways for instance we
can stretch out the gates to make them longer and thus more prone to error or we can run more gates that ultimately
result in an identity operation so the circuit doesn't actually functionally change but we purposefully sample more
noise you do have to do this for every circuit and every expectation value that you want to keep track of though so you
can see how it can end up being very expensive in terms of the time required one specific type of z& is called
probabalistic error amplification paa for short once we've learned a noise model for a gate paa works by sampling
errors from that noise model and deliberately injecting them into the circuit like I mentioned lots of new
techniques are continuing to be developed and will hopefully be implemented as we see more and more come into play there's just one final form of
error mitigation that I want to discuss called probabilistic error cancellation instead of being at the third resilience
level PE is a special capability that you have to manually turn on and kissk because the computational resources
needed for it don't scale very well compared to the other air mitigation techniques that we've discussed You
Begin by learning about the noise that's affecting your circuit by running noise learning or noise characterization
circuits for each unique layer of two Cubit Gates that are in your circuit these results let you describe the noise
in terms of poly operators once you know these noise terms you can modify your circuits so
that they effectively have the opposite PES built in to cancel these noise channels in some ways this process is
similar to that of noise cancelling headphones however this way of undoing the noise is very costly with a time to
run that grows exponentially quickly in the number of gates so it may not be the best choice for a very large circuit we
have now reached the final stage postprocessing in the end if you've done a good job and employed proper error
mitigation techniques you might see your final answer shift like like in this figure here an unmitigated distribution
shown in purple is quite far from the true expected value shown here by this line however once we apply our error
mitigation we obtain a mitigated distribution shown here in blue which Peaks much closer to the True Value now
this all comes at a cost and here we can see that the variance or the width of the distribution is increased which
isn't generally what you want but everything comes at a cost luckily we can account for this by running more
shots which causes the distribution to shrink back to an acceptable level of uncertainty so that's about it for this
lesson for next time we're going to take all of these steps and put them together and work through an area and an example
of actual application interest there's a few things that I can recommend that we do until then if you haven't yet make
sure that you download and set up kuit 1.0 you can also check out the Associated lesson for this chapter and
the previous episode in the IBM Quantum learning platform and lastly if you have any interest in digging in more and
learning more about error mitigation techniques check out one of the numerous sources that I've linked below until then we'll see you next time
[Music]